Tom Curren NBC Sports Boston Patriots
insider I woke up this morning Tom and
like most people I was thinking about
you I thought Josh Gordon's gonna end up
with another team and I still don't know
why the Patriots don't want him anymore
can you fill in the gray area here yeah
a little bit not with great hard
evidence of anything but there's a
number of circumstances that combine to
I think make Josh Gordon expendable to
the team for most they acquired Mohamed
Sanu that's going to change the
offensive geometry a little bit
secondarily I don't think that Josh
Gordon's contributions this year were
off the charts they had Nikhil Harry
coming back as well and then finally you
know with Josh Gordon there's always the
specter of where is he how dependable
will he be and not just myself but many
folks around the team have been kind of
nudge nudge told ya he wasn't as
dependable as we were looking for he was
showing up late to some things you know
and that type of thing unfortunately
it's you know what sucks did is it's a
little bit of a whisper nudge nudge
situation so I feel badly mentioning it
in some ways but it
you know it's what not just myself but
you know folks on the radio side of
things and and other B reporters have
all been told so it's a rumbling more
than a report but I think that all those
things combined throughout the Patriots
to the point of you don't want maybe
maybe we ought to move on from this you
know once burned or once bitten twice
shy and maybe we'll never find out we
still don't know why Malcolm Butler got
benched so I don't I mean the Patriots
have a great way of just moving on from
something and we don't always find out
the true story and do we know why Malcom
Butler was benched in the Super Bowl
I think it had to do with some
insubordination honestly and that's the
best thing again whisper campaign nudge
nudge hey this kind of happened but no
one goes on the
record no one will categorically say to
my the best of my knowledge it was early
in the week there was some conflict when
he was asked to go on the field for a
special teams rep and he resisted and
there was another coach he said you know
what get out there and then there was a
little bit going back and forth but
again I want to get too far into details
because again there's about 38 different
theories that one makes the most sense
to me however because when you add that
together with the Brett Bielema Michael
Bennett situation that arose recently it
kind of brought me back to that you know
they work in a bench Malcolm Butler and
suspend him for the Super Bowl but they
effectively did just put him out there
from one snap him cover a punt but as
far as we're concerned he's down for
that day all right the other story with
the Patriots the Tom Brady situation if
he's got his house up for sale which
he's had up for a while and his trainer
has his house up for sale and therefore
let's connect the dots he can opt out of
his contract and maybe he moves on from
the New England Patriots here then all
of a sudden
Jason Lakhan fora brought up a team of
maybe a landing spot for you know Brady
next year and that's the Chargers how
much of this is wishful reporting by
people I would say that it's a lot of
stuff we covered in August when Brady's
contract was renegotiated and they
didn't do anything but give him a minor
funk and no extension and the ability to
leave if he doesn't if he so chooses
because he's not going to be franchised
that was the story in August so why this
all resurfaced last week I think was
tied to the fact that he SPN on a
primetime game two hours to Phil and
said let's hit on Brady's future which I
understand we hit on Brady's future on
the regular here but it really caused
the combustible all-hands-on-deck what's
going on with Brady that was false and
not really based around anything and
then we got the next wave of speculation
which was one person says I wonder if
San Diego would work a wonder Plus
Angeles would work he's got film
interests
he's got his marketing stuff he's worked
out there and the next thing you know
it's torn out there is a likelihood he
isn't in my estimation dealing on a
daily basis or even a weekly basis with
where am I going to be next year what am
I gonna do
his trainer Alex Guerrero did have his
house on the market
he's also bought a new one in Plymouth
Massachusetts nobody I know I apologize
I mean nationally I apologize it didn't
rise to the level I know I know
okay if you had a better week's pay what
what is Brady doing next year and where
is he doing it he's doing football here
in New England he's doing football
though Dan after and this is complete
hypothesis after he does what so many
other Patriots free agents have done
that is don't get an offer from the team
go out like Dante Hightower and Devin
McCourty
and Matthew Slater and Randy Moss way
back when all did find out what's out
there and then come back and then we can
have a negotiation because Brady's
making 23 this year someone like Jimmy
Garoppolo is making about 28 and don't
put me down on the exact number but when
Brady comes back to the table with worse
numbers this year than last year yeah
the team's not going to say oh yeah
you're a year older and you have worse
numbers let's give you more money so
they're gonna want to stay away from
making an offer to him that's going to
insult him so that will be to me that's
the most likely scenario second best no
it is it is second best team in the NFC
is who the Colts with reservations
probably the Texans talent wise and when
you look at the full body of work but
Kansas City is gonna be the best second
best when when my home's gets back house
that covers them all which team would
make you most nervous if you're the
Patriots in the plans here's the city
and a healthy mo homes because when it
gets into shootout mode I don't know if
the Patriots are going to be
to keep pace with the offense as it
currently stands and it's not going to
get a hell of a lot different I'll leave
you with this who would make you more
nervous around your wife Jimmy G or Tom
Brady Brady Brady really pretty fun
record yeah she's on record all right
well I appreciate that because most
women will not go on record and saying
you know Tom Brady is good-looking cuz
I've done I've said it to my wife y'all
go hey man
Brady's a pretty handsome guy yeah not
my type
oh you don't like the handsome tight and
she was no not really a go what the hell
am I so yeah she's lying to me a little
bit because she loves beautiful men and
that's me well I noticed that by the
picture that I saw out on Twitter today
of what must be 1978 p.m. is that 78
p.m. I don't know I didn't
McLovin about it there's li retweeted I
think it looks like your yearbook
picture from high school oh I was
killing it then yeah I know yeah that
was like us I that's my Hootie the
Blowfish press pass there that was
calling you're in yeah that was college
that was yeah you go to college you know
were you in room 222
I was with Vinnie Barbarino I I was in
there a 19 since 1979 I cut my own hair
and and it looks like that right before
I had my picture taken that's yeah
that's that's yeah that's it's a good
look hair parted down the middle it's
feathered back as we like to say back in
the day maybe show that to your wife and
not you know ask her what she thinks me
or Brady yeah it's a knee buckler thank
you that's Tommy Curran NBC Sports
Boston for
dan Patrick show tune in to audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]